Frogs' legs were eaten in Britain for 7,000
years before they were eaten in France.
Oliver Cromwell was dug up and beheaded two
years after his death.
The ancient Egyptian word for 'cat' was pronounced
'miaow'.
94% of terrorist campaigns fail to achieve
a single one of their strategic goals.
Crickets produce their iconic chirping by
rubbing their forewings together.
The sound is then heard by the female via
ear-like structures on her front legs.
95% of the spiders in your house have never
been outside.
The daddy-long-legs flosses after meals by
pulling each of its eight legs through its
jaws.
The most difficult tongue-twister in English
is 'pad kid poured curd pulled cod'.
The body of the sea otter has a pouch across
the front where it keeps rocks to break open
shellfish.
The lawnmower is the most dangerous item in
the garden.
The second most dangerous is the flowerpot.
Eels can live inside sharks' hearts.
In Japan, the number 42 is considered to be
unlucky, because four and two are pronounced
as shi and ni respectively, which can be translated
“to death”.
The kite as we know it today was first invented
in China between 468 and 376 BC.
The largest known star in the universe is
VY Canis Majoris.
It sits nearly 5,000 light years from Earth
and is more than 1,540 times larger than our
Sun.
If the rest of the planet's fresh water disappeared,
there would be enough left in Lake Baikal
to supply humanity for 50 years.
The three Russian cosmonauts whose spacecraft
depressurised just before re-entry in 1971
are the only human beings to have died outside
the Earth's atmosphere.